GRAHAM, CONGRESSMAN LEE ZELDIN
AND ANN COULTER ARE ALL WITH US
TONIGHT.
THIS MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND AS WE
HONOR MORE THAN A BILLION
SERVICEMEN AND WOMEN WE COME
FACE TO FACE WITH HARD EVIDENCE
THAT THE DEEP STATE PLANNED TO
TAKE DOWN OUR DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
A DEEP STATE FROM PRESIDENT
OBAMA ON DOWN THAT DID
EVERYTHING IN ITS POWER TO
DESTROY DONALD TRUMP.
THE LATEST?
A SPY PLACED IN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
SOUND LOONEY?
LAST YEAR WE THOUGHT YOU WOULD
HAVE TO BE WEARING A TINFOIL HAT
TO BELIEVE THE  * WHEN HE SAID H
TO BELIEVE THE  * WHEN HE SAID E
HAD BEEN WIRETAPPED.
NOW WE KNOW SECRET SURVEILLANCE
WAS CONDUCTED ON AT LEAST 7
TRUMP ASSOCIATES.
AN UNMASKING OF MAYOR CANS DONE
AT A 350 PERCENT INCREASE IN AN
ELECTION YEAR BY OBAMA DEEP
STATERS.
NOW WE LEARN A SPY WAS PLACED
INTO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
YOU CAN BE SURE THERE IS MORE IN
THE INFORMATION OUT BY CONGRESS.
WILL THEY EVER ADMIT THERE WAS A
SPY?
>> IT'S MADE UP.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE HE'S GETTING
THAT FROM.
>> DO YOU FIND THAT TO BE
POSSIBLE OR PROBABLE?
LET'S PLAY DEVIL'S ADVOCATE THAT
THERE WAS A SPY INSERTED INTO
>> I DON'T FIND IT POSSIBLE AND
I KNOW IT NOT TO BE TRUE.
>> IT'S TYPICAL OF MR. TRUMP TO
MISCHARACTERIZE.
SOME LABEL SOMEONE AS A SPY WHEN
THEY ARE A CONFIDENTIAL HUMAN
SOURCE IS DOING A DISSERVICE TO
THE INDIVIDUALS AND THE FBI.
JUDGE JEANINE: LIKE MOST OF
LIARS THEY CAN'T KEEP THEIR
STORY STRAIGHT.
CLAPPER PRETTY MUCH ADMITS THERE
WAS A SPY AND HE THINKS TRUMP
SHOULD BE GRATEFUL.
>> WAS THE FBI SPYING ON TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN?
>> NO, THEY WERE NOT.
THEY WERE SPYING -- A TERM I
DON'T PARTICULARLY LIKE -- ON
WHAT THE RUSSIANS WERE DOING.
WERE THE RUSSIANS INFILTRATING
TRYING TO GAIN LEVERAGE AND
INFLUENCE WHICH WAYS THEY DO.
>> WHY DOESN'T HE LIKE THAT HE
SHOULD BE HAPPY.
>> HE SHOULD BE.
JUDGE JEANINE: IF EVER YOU
WEREN'T SURE WHO TO BELIEVE,
I'LL MAKE THIS HAPPY FOR YOU.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WAS SO
DETERMINED TO GET HILLARY
CLINTON ELECTED AND DONALD TRUMP
DEFEATED THAT THEY LET HILLARY
SKATE ON HER ILLEGAL ACTIVITY
AND CREATED A NARRATIVE ON
DONALD TRUMP.
A FALSE PREDICATE, A FAKE
DOSSIER PAID FOR BY HILLARY
CLINTON, THE DNC AND THE FBI TO
GET A COURT ORDER TO SPY ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THEY WERE ALLOWED TO SPY FOR A
YEAR.
THEY KEPT IT CLOSED.
ONLY THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE
FBI.
NOT THE FIELD OFFICE.
THEY PLANNED INSURANCE THEIR
GIRL HILLARY DIDN'T WIN.
THEY LEAKED INFORMATION HARMFUL
TO DONALD TRUMP TO THE PRESS.
IT WAS THE HEAD OF THE FBI AT
THE BEHEST OF JAMES CLAPPER WHO
PRIVATELY TOLD THE PRESIDENT
ABOUT THE FAKE DOSSIER SO THEY
COULD LEAK IT TO THE PRESS AND
THE WORLD.
WHO ARE YOU GOING TO BELIEVE?
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS CHART?
THEY ARE ALL HERE IS.
JAMES COMB WHY IT HEAD OF
JAMES -OMB WHY IT HEAD OF
JAMES --MB WHY IT HEAD OF
JAMES -- J WHY IT HEAD OF
JAMES -- JAMHY IT HEAD OF
JAMES -- JAMES IT HEAD OF
JAMES -- JAMES CT HEAD OF
JAMES -- JAMES COMHEAD OF
JAMES -- JAMES COMEYAD OF
JAMES -- JAMES COMEY.D OF
MR. LEAKER HAD TO ADMIT HE DID
SO.
COMEY LIED BEFORE CONGRESS WHEN
HE TESTIFIED HE BRIEFED THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT THE DOSSIER
BECAUSE HE LEARNED THE MEDIA WAS
ABOUT TO REPORT ON IT.
IN TRUTH COMEY BRIEFED TRUMP FOR
THE PURPOSE OF GETTING THAT
DOSSIER OUT TO THE PUBLIC.
COMEY SAID THE INVESTIGATION OF
HILLARY WAS THOROUGH.
IN TRUTH HE WROTE AN EXONERATION
MEMO LONG BEFORE THE ESSENTIAL
WITNESSES WERE INTERVIEWED.
AND THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR ANDREW
McCABE LIED SO MANY TIMES HE
HAD TO BE FIRED.
ATTORNEY GENERAL LORETTA LYNCH
WHO PUSHED TO CALL THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION A MATTER LIED WHEN
SHE SAID THERE WERE NO EMAILS
BETWEEN HER DEPARTMENT AND THE
FBI WHEN SHE USED AN EMAIL WITH
A FAKE NAME TO WRITE ABOUT HER
INFAMOUS TARMAC MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT CLINTON.
JAMES CLAPPER.
THE DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY PRETTY
MUCH LIES WHENEVER HE OPENS HIS
MOUTH.
LIKE WHEN HE LIED TO CONGRESS
WITH BETTER HIS AGENCY COLLECTED
DATA ON HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS.
HE SAID NO, NOT WITTINGLY.
AND HE LIED ABOUT THE TRUMP
DOSSIER.
JOHN BRENNAN, HEAD OF THE CIA
LIED AND SAID THE STEELE DOSSIER
WAS NOT PART OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY EVIDENCE ON INTEREST
FEARS IN THE 2016 ELECTION.
AGAIN LIARS NOT ABLE TO KEEP
THEIR STORY STRAIGHT, HE WAS
CONTRADICTED BY CLAPPER.
YOU REMEMBER SUSAN RICE.
HER LYING STARTED LONG BEFORE
BENGHAZI IN THAT DESPICABLE
VIDEO.
SHE LIED AND SAID IN THE FINAL
DAYS OF THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
SHE KNEW NOTHING ABOUT THE
SURVEILLANCE OF PRESIDENT-ELECT
TRUMP AND PEOPLE AROUND HIM AND
SHE KNEW NOTHING ABOUT
IDENTITIES BEING UNMASKED.
SHORTLY THEREAFTER SHE CAME
CLEAN TELLING HOUSE
INVESTIGATORS SHE UNMASKED
SENIOR TRUMP OFFICIALS.
THE BIG TODAY
THE -IG TODAY
THE --G TODAY
THE -- TTODAY
THE -- THEDAY
THE -- THE BY
THE -- THE BIG KAHUNA AT THE
TOP, PRESIDENT OBAMA.
HE ALLOWED THE INFORMATION TO BE
SPREAD ACROSS 16 AGENCIES
SIGNALING TO HIS PEOPLE LET IT
ALL HANG OUT AND LEAK YOUR HEART
AWAY ON TRUMP.
SO I FOR ONE AM SICK AND TIRED
OF THESE LIARS, LEAKERS AND
LIBERALS ATTACK OUR PRESIDENT
AND OUR DEMOCRACY WHEN THEY ARE
THE ONES WHO TRIED TO FRAME HIM.
HERE IS A PRIMER FOR ALL OF YOU.